[Musica]
ha consegnato in bianco
Zero Uh e poi il Nasario comincia a
muoversi come se ci fosse un fantasma
Questa è una parte del mio nuovo libro
Questa è la mia parte preferita Quanto
sono
bella
e svegliati guardagli un nuovo
aeroplanino per fare un sacco di scherzi
Oh siamo a scolo
Bravo Buongiorno
ragazzi Chi è chi è lì e Da dove salta
fuori che paura Ma che cos'è È
inquietante sono la nuova maestra
Victoria la vostra supplente per oggi
che strana questa maestra Chissà perché
si è vestita così eppure oggi non è
Halloween non lo lo so sarà il suo stile
però mi sembra molto pallida Ah questo
sole passiamo le tende però quel vestito
è davvero carino lo devo ammettere
chissà come mi starebbe e poi la mia
popolarità aumenterebbe Ah adesso si sta
molto meglio Ah una supplente ma io non
volevo fare niente oggi D'altronde ho
anche il cappellino con la A che sta per
A me non piace la
scuola bravissimo è proprio bene D il
capullo grande
Billy silenzio oggi ci sarà una verifica
scriverò alla lavagna delle domande e
voi le dovrete copiare ma come già una
verifica il primo giorno di supplenza ma
Anita Noi siamo secchioni prenderemo
sicuramente 10 Speriamo verifica Ma no
non ho studiato ma tanto noi non
studieremo comunque e poi come faccio a
scrivere Ho usato il F per fare gli
aeroplanini di
[Musica]
carta ma che fai Ma stai leggendo tu io
Ma stai scherzando Non so neanche quale
la o e la i Sto preparando il nostro
nuovo scherzo Guarda qua bellissimo da
fare alla nuova maestra Sì andiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
prepariamoci
Avete finito di scrivere No aspetti
aspetta uno per favore Dai non mi
interessa cancello lo
[Musica]
stesso
Oh
fratellino fratellino Ma come come
fratellino e da mesi che ti
cercavo Adesso tu rimani qui mentre io
faccio la lezione
Ok non ha funzion non funzionante il
nostro
scherzo Sì ma qui c'è qualcosa di strano
No non è possibile iniziate subito la
verifica gruppo sanguigno Che cos'è io
conosco solamente cose trendy e Popular
del momento di quello non ne ho mai
sentito parlare le domande di questa
verifica sono stranissime la prima
domanda è qual è il tuo gruppo sanguigno
e la seconda domanda è hai mangiato
aglio amente sono stranissime queste
domande perché questa maestra ci fa
queste domande tu hai risposto Beh sì io
ho risposto il mio gruppo sanguigno è
ABC negativo 49 plus ultra Maxi 79 - 24
per 10 Pro ma ne sei sicuro E certo lo
so da quando sono nato e alla seconda
domanda Cosa hai risposto hai mangiato
aglio ultimamente Sì perché ho mangiato
pasta aglio e olio con
Vitale gruppo sanguigno Che cos'è un
gruppo sanguigno E io che ne so eh Ah no
non è per noi Noi siamo il gruppo dei
bulli quale per il gruppo sanguigno un
altro gruppo inf Vabbè Copiamo Tanto
siamo dei Jail in questo chamo
Secure R scrivi r
[Musica]
r stavate copiando copi
No tu vieni qui ah io io ah no no mi
lasci maestra mi lasci no mi lasci no
maestra Aiutatemi
aiutat cosa hai fatto a Billy Poverino
Ora basta verifica finita adesso vi
ritiro i
compiti sì non ho scritto niente però va
bene Vabbè chi se ne frega sono un bullo
Io l'ho finito Ecco maestra io scritto
tutte le
[Musica]
risposte ragazzi
sìì poco fa quando è passata la maestra
a ritirare le verifiche lo specchio Non
la
rifletteva state pensando anche voi a
quello a cui penso io
che lo specchio di Jennifer rotto che lo
specchio riflette solo me forse che è
tempo di fare altri scherzi Dai non vedo
l'ora No sto pensando che la maestra
potrebbe essere un vero
vampiro ha consegnato in bianco
Zero Che
schifo guarda ti avrei messo cinque ma
solo per questo
[Musica]
due resposto a tutte le domande è
correttamente e non ha mangiato aglio
bene
10 quella potrebbe essere la mia
verifica perfetto Questa è andata
proprio bene ok La prima è giusta ma la
seconda ha mangiato l'aglio 10 meno
No spero di non essere io ad aver preso
10 meno sarebbe un colpo al cuore troppo
forte e non lo potrei sopportare Queste
sono le vostre verifiche un orrore
alcune ma l'ha scritto con il sangue Oh
no io ho la vista del
sangue Beh almeno ho preso
10 preso
[Musica]
10 10
meno Ah già il compito Zero meglio
dell'altra volta ho preso zero meno la
settimana scorsa Sì bene Adesso che ho
raccolto tutte le informazioni su di voi
è arrivato il momento più bello
trasformarvi in
B Oh ma cosa fa Ah mi sta mordendo
ragazzi aiuto oddio oddio i canini Ah fa
male tutto Aiuto Mi formicolano le
braccia Mi sto
trasformando
ah Adesso è il momento di trasformare
anche
voi non pensarci
neanche ah Ma che cos'è
iio brucia
brucia ce l'abbiamo fatta Abbiamo
sconfitto la maestra vampiro cattiva
Grazie al libro La Sitta stregata che
era disponibile online in libreria e io
mi sono ritrasformato Grazie
Anita